Ryan what's up buddy hey how are you hey
Richard so glad to
um speak to you I talked to you in
probably about a year ago I don't know
if you remember or not but uh everything
in my life now is pretty good
everything's uh
good and uh my question is that
in terms of like mother stock
I am
currently business is really good I'm
you know good properties good income
good job
um but I have
I would say two
I would say candidates for mother stock
um and
right now is getting to like I've been
with them like one four six years and
one for five years
do they know about each other
I actually they do and
um
and I mean it's just like a love and
hate relationship between the two and
one of them is being more
I wouldn't say demanding that she you
know would message me every other day
saying I want a baby and obviously
you know at this point
I am
27.
um
uh one is 25.
another one's 26.
okay and what do you do for a living
car rental business
okay so you do pretty good so what's
stopping you from just knocking them
both up then and having a whole bunch of
kids yeah so
so lawyer and you know let's say worst
case scenario because you know women
have reserved the right to change their
mind at any given moment let's say
hypothetically they both have one or two
children from me and one day you know
that let's you know they could go
Haywire for one would get you know
jealous or in the same household and
whatnot so
what's the you know worst case scenario
if obviously marriage marriage is out of
the picture
yeah where do you live by the way
yeah
live in Illinois
okay
um so if you're not on my email list
Ryan get on my email list because one of
the emails has a private video that I
recorded with Tristan Tate a couple
years ago yeah and it was a private
webinar you yeah like you know who the
tape brothers are obviously right yeah
yeah so I yeah so I did a video with him
privately for the guys in my community
because
um he's got uh a bunch of kids with more
than one yeah yeah
and I wanted him to talk well I knew
this a couple years ago so I wanted him
to talk about how he runs it and the
sort of problems that he runs into so we
did an hour and a bit maybe an hour and
a half or something like that so if
you're on that on that email list you'll
get that video and and he explains
exactly how he runs that
um so that's an option that's an option
that's not contemplating by a lot of
guys it's completely reasonable to do if
you absolutely want to do it you have
the financial resources and you set your
life up in such a way that you minimize
risk and protect yourself from problems
um but but this is a vetting question
this is like okay so how do I vet a
woman to become the mother of my kids
and I understand a lot of guys still
want to have kids they don't you know
they read my book they see the chapter
on why smart men don't marry and they
get it but they still want to have kids
okay fine I I will have something for
you that's that's going to be the
unplugged office guide to having kids
um the long and short of it is is it's
entirely possible it's not possible to
do it like absolutely foolproof where
you're not going to have any issues but
you can minimize the risk you can do it
with one woman you can do it with
multiple women it really depends on how
you want to set your life up and what
your objectives are there's there's some
guys that just want a ton of kids
they're like just want a dozen kids I
want 30 of them whatever you're gonna
need more than one chick to do that yeah
it's it's just it's just mandatory right
like most women can't have that many
kids you know it's an interesting story
the the
um Guinness Book of World Records the
guy that has has had the most children
on record is uh Ishmael the bloodthirsty
who was a Moroccan Sultan I can't
remember what the count was but it was
well over a thousand do you know that
the maximum number of children a woman
has ever had
I think it's it's something like 59 or
60. but during the course of all those
pregnancy she had a lot of triplets and
quadruplets and Twins and all that sort
of stuff along the way so uh multiple
kids in one pregnancy but it it's not
possible really for a woman to have more
than 70 75 kids right like it's just
doesn't exist but men have the ability
to spread C far and wide so be be open
to more than just conventional ideas is
what I'm saying but if you like the
conventional idea of one man one woman
and a bunch of kids then do that but
just you have to make sure you set it up
so that you minimize risk the first
thing that you should do is did you run
her up against my 20 red flag chapter
yes
and how many red flags do these women
have
[Music]
one has a slight uh attitude problem and
the other has
um I would I would I I don't know if I
would call jealousy a red flag
but it's in the red flag chapter extreme
jealousy the red flag yeah sometimes it
gets under my nerves where
you know she wants to know like all the
details and everything about the other
person
I don't have so much time to explain it
all day you know about that stuff but
you know okay but that but that would go
away if you were only dealing with her I
suppose right but the other one would
still have an attitude issue even if you
were just dealing with her exactly and
you see how you just use logical
reasoning to sort of evaluate you know
scenarios like this yeah I mean
I mean if let's say they're pregnant or
they have a child and then they could
easily you know just call the cops and
you know kick me out of my own home you
know and you know I could go around that
with like legal matter I could say you
know like I said my mom owns the house
or my brother owns the house or they
can't do that so I don't know if what
the I know there's no foolproof way but
you know
I'm just wondering well the one with the
attitude problem to me is a no-go right
off the bat
right because if you like why do you
want to deal with the stress of dealing
with a disagreeable woman with an
attitude
she's not disagreeable she does it I
guess in uh
submissive way like I think I would say
like purposely you know like should give
me attitude like sometimes and then
during the end of the day we're just
like bang it out does she know what I
mean so you know that I think I guess
that's the type of her personality
um
and do you want to deal with that when
she's got your kids she can really ruin
your life
no
it's just it's just something to think
about right you know like you should re
like if like the first step the first
thing you guys should do when you start
going you know through your head okay I
want to have kids should I call Rich and
ask them the best way to do that vet
them against the red flag chapter make
sure that they have no red flags or if
it's something you know like ridiculous
like they have a shopping addiction
right like that's like like number I
don't know uh number 20 on the list like
she's got an addictive personality she
buys like five lamps she brings them
home she's got to try them out on the
table and she's got to return for them
that's something that they can work on
easily
yeah when I
though I had my ex uh
with that same exact problem and you
know at the end of the day it didn't
work out because of that and
daddy issues so now so a lot more
peaceful so
all right well again you know start with
the 20 red flags
um get on my email list watch the video
with um be interested in sort of
chopping it up it's a it's a private
video you won't find it on my channel
it's it's it's just there on the email
list
um I think it's
you can't get to it directly you're
going to have to go through like eight
or nine emails will come your way but
it'll get get you eventually so do that
and then you know keep an eye open for
my course when it becomes available okay
Ryan
all right thank you so much thanks buddy
take care I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out